zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt der ehemalige
nato-general egon ramms guten abend herr
ans
herz ist dieser erfolg der ukrainischen
armee mehr als ein sag ich mal
psychologischer motivationsschub könnte
das tatsächlich eine wende in diesem
krieg bedeuten
also ich bin noch nicht so weit dass ich
von einem wendepunkt rede einfach aus
dem grunde weil ich sage sind noch zu
viele russische soldaten in der ukraine
silber und putin hat immer noch die
möglichkeit neue kräfte nach zuführen
von daher bin ich mit dieser beurteilung
ausgesprochen vorsichtig aber ich freue
mich darüber dass die ukraine diese
geländegewinne erzielt haben dabei
offensichtlich die russen überrascht
haben und damit einen guten vormarsch
gemacht haben das ist für die moral der
russischen soldaten der verbessere der
ukrainischen soldaten und für die moral
der ukrainischen bevölkerung
ausgesprochen wichtig welchen anteil
glauben sie haben denn die westlichen
waffenlieferungen am jetzigen vorrücken
der ukrainischen armee
das im einzelnen schwer zu sagen aber
mein urteil geht dahin dass ich sage
ohne die westlichen waffen ohne die
unterstützung aus den ländern europas
und vor allen dingen auch der
vereinigten staaten von amerika hätte
man diesen punkt nicht erreichen können
und das sagt auf der anderen seite das
auch gleichzeitig wieder waffen
geliefert oder weiter geliefert werden
müssen und zwar waffen aller art damit
die ukrainische armee die organische
streitkräfte diesen jetzigen erfolg
entsprechend weiter ausdehnen können und
dadurch erhöht sich jetzt auch wieder
der druck auf die bundesregierung waffen
zu liefern auch kampfpanzer leopard 2
die die ukraine ja immer freundlich
erbitten
also ich verstehe diese ganze diskussion
um schwere waffen nicht vorgelegt wenn
sie einen fleck panzer geppert nehmen
dann ist das auch ein schweres gerät mit
einer entsprechende bewaffnung die man
auch im bodenkampf einsetzen kann und
hier zu fantasieren beispielsweise auch
leopard gegen zu setzen gegen
panzerhaubitzen auch beim service lahm
ein großes kaliber das ist für mich eine
theoretische und eigentlich völlig
überflüssige diskussion
erstaunlich ist ja auch dass die
russischen truppen jetzt trotz ihrer
übermacht so
richtig weg sind was ist ihre analyse
was da auf russischer seite eigentlich
passiert
also einmal von der unmittelbaren
wirkung auf die soldaten ich schätze
dass die soldaten durch den ukrainischen
angriff oder die angriffe entsprechend
überrascht worden sind man sich
offensichtlich nicht darüber im klaren
war dass man in einer solchen situation
vielleicht auch mit seinen waffen und
mit seinem gerät ausweichen muss und man
ist offensichtlich regelrecht weg
gelaufen das hat sowohl die führung
gefehlt als auch kampfkraft und wille
und moral der russischen soldaten da
kommen mehrere faktoren zusammen zum
vorteil der ukraine haben sie den
eindruck dass dieser krieg jetzt in eine
entscheidende in eine in einem jahr in
eine endphase geht oder ist das noch wir
zufrieden
ich glaube das ist noch zu früh wenn die
angriffe der ukraine im süden also
person in dem bereich ebenfalls so
erfolgreich wären diese geht's im osten
raumschiff sind dann würde ich sagen
jawohl es könnte ein wendepunkt erreicht
sein aber noch sehe ich das nicht so und
hier empfehle allen die sich mit diesem
thema beschäftigen das vielleicht noch
mal ein paar wochen zu beobachten
wenn die ukraine den 24 august ihren
nationalfeiertag im nächsten jahr hohen
russische soldaten auf die am boden
feiern kann dann wären wir schon ein
riesenerfolg
ok general ramms plädiert für vorsicht
und geduld vielen dank herr amts für
ihre einschätzung